visiteurs de prestige dans cette
coopérative viticole de chablis en
costume cravate ou au tailleur venue de
zambie croatie ou des philippines
tous sont ambassadeurs de france ils
connaissent le chablis mais j'aimerais
le faire découvrir dans leurs pays
respectifs
pour l'instant le vin et surtout sud
africain c'est plus proche c'est moins
cher ils le connaissent mieux mais nous
on fait des opérations
une opération beaujolais nouveau au 14
juillet on sert des vins français
notamment du chablis en serveur orbi
donc au moins à ma table on sert du
chablis mais j'aimerais bien que le vin
français soit plus connue hors d'afrique
australe
deux tiers des vins de chablis partent à
l'exportation essentiellement en grande
bretagne et aux usa après la découverte
des cuvées de la mise en bouteille
les ambassadeurs déguste différents crus
pour les producteurs locaux
une première étape vers de nouveaux
marchés potentiels tout alors justement
un ambassadeur qui les intéressaient qui
voulait savoir comment ils pouvaient
importer faire importer les 25 min dans
son pays la moldavie en l'occurrence
dont vous voyez concrètement après
certainement une mise en relation qui
est tout à fait possible entre des
opérateurs chablisien et puis des
importateurs des distributeurs dans ces
différents pays
le vin la gastronomie le patrimoine la
région bourgogne franche comté a de
nombreux atouts à faire valoir
le premier secteur c'est le tourisme
parce que on voit effectivement des pays
où le tourisme se développe énormément
et qui dont les ambassadeurs nous disent
que manifestement la france les
intéressent et qu'il y a un potentiel
parce que ces pays se développe
les ambassadeurs ont terminé leur
journée dans l'yonne par la visite du
port de gron chargé de céréales des
bateaux partiront bientôt peut-être
d'ici pour l'ukraine ou la côte d'ivoire